you
[Music]
[Music]
and then there's women like Molin who
need your help
so for you to get what if these shoes
[Music]
so this is where the works the bakken
women becomes real with all of our
nations and support that have been
flooding in we wanted to show you
exactly what's happening and the lives
that we're transforming rebuilding
kiosks to be able to give it to these
woman's create businesses for themselves
that's providing an education food
housing and rebuilding their lives and a
whole to be better equipped to deal with
anything that's thrown at them and as I
said before that it's a huge success
rate for these women and it's impactful
and the fact that we can come together
we've forgotten willing to provide this
it's just so important and it's a whole
family that then goes on to have a
better future and a better life and we
only deserve that whatever country were
in so please keep helping keep donating
because this is really happening
and we're really transforming lives now
and for the better so this is what I
serve the lady that inspired this whole
project and we've come to visit her
quickly before we leave tomorrow and we
are so happy to say that all her drinks
are gone dudes were local with him and
this for us is what it's all about so
yeah
[Music]
[Music]